choisi comme on s'y attendait le groupe
conduit par radio berlusconisme et
patron du figaro et du premier groupe de
presse français entrent donc dans la
tâche le paysage audiovisuel français
après ces deux derniers avaient connu la
consommation il reste donc en place
il est engagé sur le rallye s'inscrit de
lui même dans les nécessités
commerciales de la fête au delà de la
nécessité politique et je dois vous dire
à ce sujet de notre choix a été fait de
faire un tour de table du rallye portant
une télévision qu'ils le soient même si
ça ne m'empêche pas par ailleurs de
faire des journaux
froid mais plus maintenant